el día de hoy portugal entró en estado
de emergencia que implica este estado de
emergencia que habrá confinamiento
obligatorio a partir de las 11 de la
noche hasta las 5 de la mañana de lunes
a viernes y los fines de semana será a
partir de la una de la tarde es una
medida que va a afectar en gran parte al
sector de comercios restaurantes y
turismo y de hecho ya se han registrado
protestas en el país
al respecto el día de hoy en la mañana
se registró una protesta importó
precisamente de los dueños de
establecimientos comerciales y
restaurantes que aseguran después son
los fines de semana los días en que más
recepción de personas tienen y si ahora
tienen que cerrar a la una de la tarde
pues no les queda tiempo y no les queda
oportunidad para recuperarse de esta
crisis que ya tiene varias meses
afectando también implica en este estado
de emergencia el hecho de que se pueda
tomar la medida corporal de la
temperatura corporal en establecimientos
para entrar instituciones también para
la entrada a los colegios no se
sorprenden las clases es una luz muy
importante en todo el territorio
nacional todavía están abiertos todos
los colegios pero si habrá restricciones
de movilidad esta pista a 121 municipios
en todo el país